who is funding the race to elect
nevada's next supreme court judge
thanks for staying with us i'm denise
feldes and i'm brian loftis the i-team
looked at election records finding
hundreds of thousands of dollars flowing
into this race and others the i-team's
david charns is here
and david what did you find well brian
there are more than 130 judges on the
ballot across our state this election
cycle look four pages there
a lot of attention has gone to just one
specific race we're talking about the
one for the open supreme court seat that
is c-d in the i-team found the district
attorney right here in clark county
donated to one candidate's campaign
and that's raising questions about
independence on the bench
you've seen the ads i'm judge doug
herndon i'm ozzie fumo and i'm running
for nevada state supreme court
assemblyman ozzy fumo and clark county
district court judge doug herndon
vying for an open state supreme court
scene the i-team found
they're getting help to get there
campaign finance reports show hundreds
of thousands of dollars flowing in from
lawyers and big name law firms
even the clark county district attorney
some who could one day show up
in front of the bench the nevada bar
prohibits a lawyer from quote
seeking to influence a judge by means
prohibited by law
it basically prevents a lawyer from
bribing a judge but campaign donations
to a judge
who could one day try your case that's
perfectly legal
both campaigns say it's not about the
money but remaining independent
in the courtroom it's all about
integrity and if you have it
nothing else matters and if you don't
have it nothing else matters
you've either got the ability to be
independent or you don't
and if you're going to be not
independent then you have no business
being in court period
a 2015 report from the brennan center
for justice finds
63 percent of donations made to supreme
court candidates nationwide
comes from lawyers lobbyists and other
business interests
in all from small donations to the ten
thousand dollar cap fumo has raised
three hundred thirty six thousand
dollars
to herndon's seven hundred seventy six
thousand it raises
questions about at the very least
perception dr francis carlton is a
political science professor at the
college of southern nevada
he says the constitution protects
donations as a form of free speech
you have one side before the judge
that's given a contribution and the
other side hasn't
right that's that's when it can be most
problematic so how could the campaign
for clark county district attorney steve
wolfson
donate 2 500 to herndon's campaign
judge herndon says the two men are
longtime colleagues i don't think that
impacts my ability to be impartial and i
don't think
look twenty five hundred dollars is a
lot of money obviously but i don't think
in the context of a campaign
it's an amount of money that would make
anybody say wow you can't be impartial
now because you know that guy gave you
that much money
in a statement wolfson said in part my
support is determined by my personal
knowledge of the candidate's
qualifications
in my belief that they are the best
choice to fill the position adding
nothing bars him from supporting one
candidate over the other it comes in a
sense
a leap of faith that is not inaccurate
to say that
carlton says because the law is clear
donations to judicial campaigns are
legal
we simply have to put our trust in an
independent court
once you have those you're going to have
the issue of campaign contributions
so on top of the donations made to the
candidates that we just showed you
political action committees or pacs you
may know that name
they can indirectly finance all these
candidates as well both fumo and herndon
say they are aware of at least one pack
working in each of their favors and
that's pumping even more money
into this race denise so david we should
remind our viewers here that certainly
we elect our judges here in nevada but
that is not the case across the country
no so most judges elect uh most states
that is elect judges like we do but
some states have governors or lawmakers
actually appoint them sort of like how
it's done on the federal level like we
just saw on the supreme court
some advocates who want to get money out
of these races say possible fixes
include a public fund
where candidates can then all draw money
from a big pot to pay for advertising or
just having no judicial elections at all
brian denise
all david thank you